رئيس ريال مدريد يتوج بجائزه الفتى الذهبي
اريكسون يمثل الدنمارك في المونديال وكيف
تفاعل النجوم البرازيل مع قائمه كاس
العالم هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من
العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
بعمر ال 75 حقق رئيس ريال مدريد
جائزه الفتى الذهبي لافضل رئيس نادي للعام
الحالي وتسلم في غزه الجائزه المقدمه من
طرف الصحيفه الايطاليه توتو سبورت في مقر
نادي في العاصمه الاسبانيه مدريد بعد فوزه
باغلبيه الاصوات
[موسيقى]
قائمه البرازيل لكاس العالم
عشاق كره القدم حول العالم ومعهم لاعبوا
المنتخب البرازيلي هيدرو نجم فلامنجو امام
العائله والاصدقاء تقدم مباشره لطلب
الزواج من صديقته بعد ظهور اسمه في قائمه
المنتخب النهائيه الامور كانت اهداف في
بيت نيمار جونيور نجمه سان جيرمان الذي
تبع القرعه رفقه ابنها وبعض الاصدقاء
في المونديال
بعد 17 شهرا من توقف قلبه خلال مباراه كره
القدم اختيار النجم كريستين اريكسون ضمن
قائمه الدنمارك المشاركه في مونديال قطر
المقبل الكثيرون التنبؤوا بنهايه مسيره
اريكسون بعد نوبه القلبيه اصابته خلال
مباراه منتخب بلاده في كاس اوروبا 2020
وفصخ عقده مع نادي انتر بعدها لكن
كريستيان تمكن من العوده الى الملاعب
والظفر بما كان اساسي في تشكيله مانشستر
يونايتد
وفي مباراه لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه فاجاء
اللاعب مارسن اوليسكي الجميع بهدف
اكروباتي رائع خلال مباراه افريقيا
وارتباز ضمن البطوله البولنديه هودس
سوشيال ميديا طالبوا بترشيح الهدف لجائزه
بوشكاش المقدمه من الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم لاجمل هدف في السنه
[موسيقى]